one of the most important pieces to the
persona series and a major reason why we
remember each game so fondly is the
soundtrack each main line persona game
and spin-off has their own memorable
songs that encapsulate their defining
moments and with persona 3 dancing in
moonlight and persona 5 dancing in
starlight those evocative soundtracks
are brought to the forefront for fun
exhilarating rhythm games with their own
charming personalities taking center
stage
[Music]
both use the rythm gameplay system first
established in persona 4 dancing all
night six button inputs bordered the
screen and notes flow from the center
out to the corresponding input double
notes holds and DJ scratches with the
flick of an analog stick keep you on
your toes which makes things
delightfully hectic on the highest
difficulties
it's an incredibly fun rhythm system
that's supported by note patterns that
flow seamlessly with the beautiful track
lists there's an undeniable satisfaction
to nailing perfect combos as the claps
tambourines and scratches sync with the
beat of the song it's not far off to say
that you feel the rhythm but note
patterns will come naturally as you grow
familiar with each track all the while
the casts of each game dance with
impressive fluidity especially with how
partner and group dances are
choreographed with a natural
imperfection
everyone's expressive and going all-out
whether it's the phantom thieves dancing
deep into a hostile palace or seas
getting down atop Tartarus during the
dark hour
[Music]
now I'll be the first to admit that
there's a thematic dissonance between
dancing and flashy outfits and persona
three's darker tone which might be
off-putting for die-hard fans of that
game still the fact that we see these
old locations recreated with modern
visuals is a trip you were taught I
station polonium all the get coke on
high entrance and rooftop Tartarus it's
all here and it's an absolute delight to
be with the Seas crew again reincarnated
and 3d models in the same vein as
persona 5 art style
it's a reimagining of yukari's joyful
demeanor Mitsuru Stern attitude and June
pays goofiness I do wish we had Shinji
from the start but he's available as DLC
and sadly car Omar was missing but it's
an overwhelming feeling like seeing old
friends in a new light most of all
dancing in moonlight stands out with a
tracklist that spans the course of
persona threes history which includes
songs from persona 3 fests persona queue
and persona 3 portable it gives a
musical variety that's attached to so
many great memories but that's also
exciting to play the remixes and
remasters evoke not just a sense of
nostalgia but have a newfound quality
that breathes new life into persona 3
particularly songs like heartful cry
when the moon reaches for the stars burn
my dread memories of you the list goes
on
dancing in moonlight carries this
powerful legacy
[Music]
when it comes to persona 5 dancing at
starlight the swagger and style of the
phantom thieves bursts at the scenes its
scene in a wink and a nod as they move
in a way that fits their personalities
they'll be getting down in familiar
locations like mementos Shibuya crossing
and shootin academy in the theme song
groovy that's so beautifully drawn and
animated you can't help but feel that
they had the moves in them a number of
great songs like rivers in the desert
blooming villain and life goes on are
featured here and of course the best
Palestine price has Makoto throwing it
down in front of the bank in the sky
[Music]
the wonderful fusion of jazz metal and
downtempo make for a great playlist that
feels like a trip through the struggles
and triumphs of persona 5 all over again
there are a few decent remixes though
they don't shine as brightly as they do
in persona 3 there are also a few
shortcomings and dancing in starlight
when it comes to presentation life will
change an empowering song with
infectious confidence is paired with a
fairly cheesy music video more
importantly it's unfortunate that the
female cast gets over sexualized in the
last surprise music video which is some
sort of bizarre burlesque show that's
out of touch out of place and wholly
unnecessary
[Music]
unlike persona 4 dancing all night there
is no traditional story mode in either
game outside of dancing both games
features social events where
conversations with your squad take place
the premise is that they're stuck in a
dream state where your velvet room
representative asks you to dance it's
silly but it's enough to provide the
context necessary for the social events
a series of neat scenes where characters
simply banter there isn't much in the
way of new character development aside
from their newfound determination to
dance social events play off of what you
already know about the cast's akiko is
still obsessed with getting strong and I
guess is still working her way around
typical human mannerisms on striving to
be the next top model and use Ches
enraptured by his artistic side
regardless it's nice to chill with them
again and watch them go back and forth
with each other especially since the
original voice cast returned for both
games social events also provide
incentives for playing the game in
different ways each character has
specific conditions for unlocking their
social events like passing songs using
certain modifiers or writing several
outfits or accessories during your time
playing it's well worth it especially
for the room visits even if it's just a
dorm room or the attic of LeBlanc coffee
shop visiting these places in
first-person breathes new life into
worlds you thought you knew each game
has 23 tracks and eight short social
events for every crew member but it's so
easy to get lost in these songs both old
and new memories of the original RPGs
and all the games in between come
flooding back
they're also annoyed
their own right like the game itself the
opening theme our moment is a
celebration of persona 3 and the journey
with C's despite its dark undertones the
unapologetic confidence and style of
persona 5 s phantom thieves comes
through vividly and their own theme song
that's inspiring all over again
these unique soundtracks take center
stage and showcase the incredible work
of series composer Shoji maguro and
company the rhythm gameplay system and
the songs are perfect matches
but there's something particularly
special about persona 3 dancing and
moonlight it's in the suite remixes and
remasters of familiar songs recreations
of places we've been and the
re-imagination of characters we've long
known I'm also not going to overlook a
chance to revisit the Phantom thieves in
persona 5 dancing at starlight you may
find the overall premise a little
strange and you won't find character
development beyond what's already been
established in the past but if you let
loose just as the cast have done for
these games you'll find brilliant fun
rhythm games and some of the best songs
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you